Oh folks I hope everybody can see me and
hear me YouTube made some changes I'm
still catching up to see if I can
understand what they're doing here but
anyways I hope you can hear me fine
anyways welcome to rational science
welcome to the end of the world at least
as we know it you have to give me credit
for that yeah I've had a theory for now
twenty years in which I say that man is
soon to become extinct our species will
wither away in fact not wither it'll
kind of go with a bang okay and one
thing I want to say about that is that a
lot of people introduce things into my
theory which are not there which I never
said okay I want to clarify that a lot
of people talk about the rich and
powerful
the Illuminati maybe even the Jews or
the Chinese taking over the world that's
not part of my theory okay just want to
clarify that I'm not saying it doesn't
happen I'm not saying it does happen I
don't care if you believe or don't
believe all I'm saying is that's not
part of the theory the theory says that
no matter what we do whether we stand on
our heads no matter what anyone does on
planet Earth okay we will become extinct
okay there were as far as I know there
were no Illuminati among the T Rexes
okay you know they died the same way
we're gonna die we have to die in the
same way they died
and if they had no Illuminati then
obviously Illuminati or rich people
powerful people play no specific role in
the theory of extinction okay and again
it means that we have to imitate
whatever happened to the dinosaurs the
Permian synapsids and so on in other
words we're gonna die in the same way
all day all of them died and how did
they die well
their economics fell apart okay their
whole world economic world fell apart
what does that mean it means that you
know an animal also has economics you
know they don't have the economics that
we're thinking of you know money and
interest rates and banking and all that
stuff no no they have a little different
type of economics the economics of a
wild animal is food that's what they
manage management of resources that's
economics that's what they meant they
manage food okay and you know when the
Triceratops
stock market goes down well the terrace
get the t-rex has suffered big losses so
to speak okay so that's what happened to
them and we're gonna have the same
situation you know when when our food
runs out then we're gonna go extinct why
we'll run the food run out because we
manage all that through money through
this abstraction that we created and the
theory says that money will be no more
and there is no other theory on planet
Earth like it so whether you believe in
it or not at least you have to grab that
it's a new theory
you won't hear it anywhere else the
theory is money will be no more the
global economic system that man created
will fall apart when it does not if it
does but when it does no one will have
incentives to produce or distribute food
to the cities no intervention by
Illuminati no intervention by the Jew is
no intervention by the Chinese or the
Russians or none of that okay there
there is no provision for that in the
theory that's all I'm saying
ok ok the other issue I wanted to talk
about real quick or clarifying is that a
lot of people a lot of the people who do
not understand I believe that's that's
the best word I can use they don't
understand the rope hypothesis the the
thread theory is as is also known
they don't understand it because they
harp on the wrong issue and the issue is
word object that that's the key issue
that's why I'm saying though the word
object destroys all religions what is
the issue there the issue is that these
people are saying okay why can't I touch
the rope why can't I see the room I mean
there's gazillions of ropes converging
on an atom okay and those gazillions of
atoms we can't see any of those ropes
why not
well again the definition of the word
object is not that which you can see or
touch the definition of the word object
is that which has shape the rope has
shape it meets the definition of the
word object so far so good or we have
you problems there so anyone raising an
issue of touch and see why can't we see
why can't we touch well I have to
believe that it has a mental problem
because I don't know how else to clarify
to that person that the definition of
object is not that which you can touch
or see and and I've got a good example I
mean we have gazillions of atoms and
molecules of air hitting our eyes this
very moment they're they're they're
gazillions of them and we can't see a
single one and the air we're talking
about atoms and molecules and here we're
talking about something gazillions of
times thinner smaller flatter you know
whatever you're talking about something
that is much thinner than the diameter
of a hydrogen atom and so you're asking
to see something that you cannot see
that you cannot touch therefore it is
irrational for someone to raise the see
touch criteria first and second to say
let's go to the lab to see if you can
demonstrate the existence of the ropes
these people are demented they're what I
called idiots okay they they don't have
little ideas they have big
ideas and so it's ideas there they're
idiots
so yeah anyone who talks about
experiment demonstrating probing
presenting evidence touching scene using
any other senses is a mental [ __ ]
individual because he can't follow a
rational explanation a rational
mechanism that is proposed to him and
especially you can't follow definitions
they give lip services to definition
they say oh yeah that's an object is
that what you can touch us now which has
shape they concede it but they don't
know what they conceded they sold their
soul to the devil and they don't realize
it because now they can't bring in the
see touch criteria you know you can't
say you're gonna touch the rope you
can't say you're gonna touch magnetism
the the mediator of magnetism you can't
touch or see the mediator of gravity and
they said what there's gazillions a rope
why can't I see it well because that's
not the criteria the criteria for Abdi
is that which has shape and mother
nature specifically made the rope
invisible in touchable under untouchable
under any circumstance and how do you
get that thought to these people so yeah
they have serious
I think it's mental problems because
they can't follow a rational explanation
and primarily because they don't pay
attention to definitions they're not
consistent with their definitions they
give lip service to them okay last week
we talked or last time we talked about
time and one of the things we found out
is the math magicians have no idea what
time is here we've had this word at
least since the days of the Greeks
because we had good old Aristotle area
as I call Aristotle you know he talked
about time and he talked about in his
word work called physics okay and so
we've had this word for a long time and
here we are two thousand plus years
later and not a single math magician on
earth from Canberra all the way to
Carver candy find the word time we had
Stephen Hawking his
brief history of time of 1988 and you
won't find it defined there and you say
hold that this guy's a physicist so
called physics and mathematical
physicist he's an expert on all these
equations he uses time every in every
question that he writes almost and he
doesn't know what time is he can't
define the word time he even concedes
that he doesn't know what time is so so
we have a problem because here we have
all these mathematicians and they say
look I'm gonna use time for this for
this I'm gonna put seconds in my
equation but they don't know what time
is now you figure that out and in just
in case you know they don't know any of
those words they don't know what field
is they don't know what mass is they
don't know what point is they don't know
what a line is none of the words that
they use do they have a definition a
scientific definition for them and so we
don't know what they're talking about
but they claim through those definitions
that they can interpret how this
universe works for you and when you say
well how does this work how does that
work they say well you got to study math
okay so that's the answer you got to
study man you didn't study man you want
to understand okay so what did air you
do well arrey he did talk about time and
before he got the time he started first
with defining words such can such as
continues what continuity meant to him
what infinity meant then he went into
place and then he went later on to time
into motion okay so this is where he
started that's where I'm gonna take over
from the other day I'll just follow up
and here we have Google Airy and first
thing that they did together with you
clean who came a little later right they
tried to define what an object is very
loosely they never gave any importance
to this definition which is the number
one definition you have to have in
physics they didn't realize first the
importance of that definition and second
they had the right notion but then they
never use that
Oshin for anything okay and that's
that's where the problem is
so Euclid said I what is an object
essentially okay a boundary is that
which an extremity
of anything and what is a figure is that
which is contained by any boundary or
boundaries so more or less they have the
right idea or you clean have the right
idea that an object is that which has
shape which has something around it will
cut a surface a perimeter a boundary
call it whatever you want we get the
idea the idea was very close if it's not
right on the money it's very close to it
okay and he had the same idea before him
I guess they got this from their
ancestors as well you know says bounded
by a surface is the definition of body
I think it's straightforward right so
these guys had this notion that a body a
thing an entity a substance is that
which has shape which is the definition
that we haven't right rational science
that was a shape you want to call it
surface that which a surface that which
has perimeter and outline fine no
problem as long as we were on more or
less on the same page okay okay so what
is the problem with us well they went on
to the next word or at least Aristotle
did and this is what he did he says he
defined place okay so what is a place
position or location well area says
places the boundary of the body which
contains it so you say that place is a
boundary and he just said that boundary
bounded you know a boundary belongs to a
body so essentially he's saying place is
a body he's treating location in other
words you could say location or position
the site occupied by the tree when you
pull the tree out that hole that he left
behind
that's a standalone object according to
area it's got shape it's got boundaries
and he continues just to make sure you
you understood in case you missed it
right says police is this boundary
itself contains no extension
over and above the bulk of the body
which comes to be in it places what
contains that of which it is the place
place is no part of the thing place can
be left behind by the thing and is
separable ok so what is good or are you
telling us well he's saying that place
is a standalone object place has surface
place has perimeter and when you remove
the tree or the dog or the rock you're
leaving a hole behind that has the shape
of whatever you pulled out and the only
way an object can exist if it occupies a
place but then it's like it's a hole
waiting for it to be occupied and of
course this hole changes shapes because
if you put a dog in that place and you
replace it with a rock well the rock
might have a little different shape than
the dog or a 3 for that matter right and
I guess shape changes its its shape
depending on the object that occupies it
that was his notion ok so what would the
big problem here is that he's treating
place as a physical object and he
doesn't realize that and asks again
because he didn't pay attention to what
he defined he defined object or
substance or thing body as he called it
as that which has a surface that which
has shaped that which has a perimeter
and then he applies that same definition
to play saying a place also does have a
boundary so what are we going to learn
here we're gonna have this concept
called place right and this place is
also gonna have a boundary it's gonna be
an object essentially by definition ok
ok from there he moves out the time so
what is time well here we have an idea
what he with notion he had of time ok
time is infinite time indeed and
movement or Infant so first thing he
says they're both infinite why because
you can chop them into pieces and you
can add more time to it
either way ok you can also for in the
case of motion you can add more meters
and if you have 1 meter of length you
can chop that up into little pieces as
much as you want so in both directions
division and addition it's infinite ok
so time is a measure of motion in a
being moved motion always exists
therefore time exists ok that that was
his reasoning
he says time is number meaning I guess
the translation I didn't like the
translation very much because I don't
know what number of motion means I think
he meant the amount of motion ok so time
is amount of motion that's asbestos I
can understand what he's saying their
type is not movement but only movement
insofar as it admits enumeration so as
soon as you put numbers according to
area right as soon as you put numbers to
motion now you're dealing with time and
I don't know what exactly what that
really means because I can put meters to
motion and that's not time but I guess
in his little mind he thought he
answered the question ok ok so what is
motion that's the subject of today one
of the subjects the other one is the
fact that we're gonna have concepts that
are gonna be moved around that's get
scary because you're gonna need 10 beers
to understand that ok so please go to
your friends get your beers now and
suffer later ok here it is
ok here we have an area talking about
motion ok it begins by defining says to
define the infinite you must use
quantity ok so you're gonna deal with
math here in order to talk about
infinite or infinity right in your
format but not substance you cannot use
a body you cannot talk about an infinite
body meaning extended body that is
infinitely extended you said you can't
talk about that you can only talk to you
use the word infinite or infinity in the
context of quantity ok ok we have no
problem with that there the
mathematicians want to use the word
infinite in terms of number lines the
problem we have no problem of that keep
it keep
you're in your own dog house don't bring
it out here okay don't bring it into
physics okay because physics deals with
substance with bodies with things and if
you're going to talk about a number line
then the fact that you can add numbers
to numbers and forever or cut a number
into all kinds of little pieces well
that's fine in mathematics just don't
bring it to physics because it's got
nothing to do with a physical world that
mother nature runs she doesn't know math
okay she only deals with objects with
bodies out there in everywhere really
but especially out there in the universe
okay motion is supposed to belong to the
class of things love the fact that he
treats motion as a thing he uses this
word he's got to use a word he's gonna
use the word thing is he saying that
motion is a body is it stand-alone
substance thing entity so so he uses the
word thing and that's that's part of the
problem I don't know if there could be
something lost in the translation okay
we have to concede that there could be a
problem there as well I don't know Greek
so I can't tell you exactly what he said
or what he meant all I can go is with
translation and they use the word thing
okay so we use the word thing to refer
to everything like concepts and objects
and everything now in physics we make a
distinction a concept and an object
those are two different things
okay objects are things because they
have shape concepts are just nouns that
require first of all they don't have
shape but then every concept requires
two objects so it's a relation between
two objects okay
that's important to know the distinction
to understand that distinction between
concept and object every word in the
dictionary can put under can be put
under one or the other category either
it is an object or it's a concept either
it has shape or it doesn't have shape
either it's a standalone object the only
one in the universe that you when you
present it you point to it or it's a
relation
between two objects okay so concepts and
object are separate there are two
different types of words you can't mix
them and he's gonna mix them he's gonna
he's gonna say that motion is some kind
of thing bad word II should have said
suburb not a thing but okay let's
continue which are continuous and the
infinite presents itself first in the
continuous in other words he's gonna
relate infinity with continuity with
continuous okay what is infinitely
divisible is continuous and again that
was his notion of infinity okay that if
you can be top it up into pieces you got
infinity you can do it forever okay
something in half as long as it's not of
something it's a number and you can do
whatever you want right even location
maybe I don't know you know you could
say that a concept you can chop up into
as much as you want and he called that
potential infinity right that you can
imagine you can conceptualize dividing a
number or a location as many times as
you want okay that that was his notion
this is motion in this most general and
primary sense is change of place which
we call locomotion so what was the
problem there well the problem is this
word change see change is already motion
there's no such thing as change without
motion so he's using a synonym because
change is a synonym of the word motion
and here we have here we have a
definition of change just in case okay
definition of change that you find today
in the dictionary because the dictionary
still defines to this day motion
everybody in fact does all kinds of
dictionaries especially specialize this
and they'll all define it the same way
they say what has changed changes to
make different and just look at the
verbs to make to transform or convert to
substitute and take to transfer the
transfer to get to remove and replace
all verbs what has changed
a verb that's what it is for the
purposes of physics in ordinary speech
it's a noun
not in not in fizzy physics change means
motion and motion means change because
they're sending them and we have to
define that word and we can't say that
motion has changed now motion is two or
more locations of an object now we can
understand it we didn't use any synonyms
that you find the word motion okay
so what is the definition that the good
old mathematicians today have that they
have inherited from mr. Aristotle and
here you have a couple of them okay
couple of definitions the first one I'd
like to mention is position why because
position according to mathematics okay
here's the definition says a Euclidean
vector vector is already motion so
position which is a static concept is
defined in terms of a vector which is a
dynamic concept fine that represents the
position of a point P in space in
relation to the arbitrary reference
origin Pole so what are we saying we're
saying that you put a stake in the
ground okay and you draw two lines from
there and we're gonna make this
Cartesian coordinates on the ground
right and all that position is the
number of steps that you need to find a
treasure chest five five steps this way
ten steps that way right and you you
reach your treasure chest so position is
motion according to the Mathemagician
because they're giving you instructions
on how to get there
that's what position is from a
mathematical point of view so position
is motion what is motion motion is the
change again wrong word motion is the
change in the position of an object over
time I like the fact that they use the
word time to define motion when you're
supposed to define motion before you
define time can you define time without
motion obviously not so so again is
circular because they put the word time
to define the word motion it should be
the other way around you should not be
you should not need
you use the word time to define the word
motion motion needs to be defined before
time there's got to be an order in which
you defined terms in physics you can't
just define them in any old way and say
I'm gonna do you find exists before I
did you find object or define before
that you find location doesn't work that
way okay you have to define them in the
proper order because one because you got
to build the definitions on simpler
concepts are more on more fundamental
concepts okay change a difference in the
state of affairs at different points in
time again change defined in terms of
time and so none of these people ever
learn how to define words scientifically
that's why we have no no not one note
scientific definitions of any word in
mathematical physics not one especially
not one of the important ones maybe I
don't know maybe the the word house has
a definition in mathematical physics I
don't know but the point here is that
they don't have any definitions of the
important words that they're going to
use that's the first issue the second
one is that all of them contain motion
all the concepts used by mathematical
physics are concepts really and they're
all dynamic concept so you all have
motion embodied in them and that's what
I want to show next ok ok so what are
these dynamic concepts well here you
have a series of words that the
mathematicians use every day these words
are outlawed in science they're outlawed
in physics first because they're they're
not defined they're undefined terms
that's the first problem the second
problem is that they are concepts and
third is that these concepts are dynamic
concepts that means that you can't say
that you got to move a dynamic concept
okay and here I have an example so that
you see where I'm going with all this
okay let's see if I can get it up here
okay here we have a kangaroo on the Left
that's an object for the purpose of a
physics the one on the right
the so called jumping kangaroo is not a
kangaroo and people don't understand
that that's not a kangaroo that's called
a jumping kangaroo jumping kangaroo is
not a kangaroo you can't say a jumping
kangaroo
move the house or a jumping kangaroo
jumped over the house you can't say that
in physics because the kangaroo is
already jumping what you have on the
right is a dynamic concepts already
being qualified with an adverb and
jumping in this case is an adverb
because it qualifies motion just like
swimming is an adverb just like flying
is an adverb these are not nouns these
are not nouns they're not adjectives
they are adverbs they qualify motion and
so again the problem here is that all
these words that these people use the
see if I can get them back up here again
all these words are dynamic concepts so
you can't say you're gonna transfer
energy you can't say you're gonna move a
mass you're gonna wave the wave or
vibrate the way or extend the field all
the way to the edge of space-time
all those are irrational statements
because they're already dynamic concepts
you can't stretch a dynamic concept you
have to have a net you have to identify
what is the object and if you don't
identify the object you're not doing
physic you're doing irrationality only
okay and then they get my point across
okay I don't care if you agree with it
or not you better have a good reason for
your not agreed okay so let's go with
the first one here's energy okay so what
is energy the first thing is if you
define a word it's not enough it can't
be an object in sense we do not define
objects in science we point to objects
okay
we point to them name them and someone
then identifies the image that's in
front of them with the word that you
pronounce so if you want to teach an ET
your language you say three and you
point and say three and et looks he sees
three
stand-alone object it's the only object
in the universe that thing that's in
front of them and it's called three okay
that's how you present objects and
physics if you can't do it that way it's
not an object okay okay so what happens
first thing is energy head lacks the
definition okay there's no definition
for it and here we have testimony we all
we need proof and evidence to convince
and recruit right and so here we have
mr. Fineman he says it is important to
realize that in physics today we have no
knowledge of what energy is and so what
are the biggest spirits of quantum
mechanics is this famous word energy
it's been around at least since the days
of Aristotle no one has any idea what
energy is okay and and then what's the
next issue the experts say that they
have no idea what energy is and then it
says yet Mathemagician say universe came
from energy the universe popped into
existence from energy specifically the
break up of positive and negative energy
and here we have a testimony again proof
evidence for all those who want to be
convinced and recruited and converted
etc okay here's mr. Hawking saying it in
his book a brief history of time he says
that the Big Bang itself the universe is
thought to have had zero size there are
something like bla bla bla bla bla
millions millions of a with 8000
Tagore's in the region of the universe
that we can observe where did they all
come from yeah what did they the answer
is that in quantum theory particles can
be created out of energy uh-huh
in the form of particle/anti-particle
pairs okay how do our energy became a
particle that that's gotta be an
interesting mechanism that he can show
us okay or he explained to us okay not
show us but explain to us but that just
raises the question where the energy
came from yeah I guess from God the
answer is that the total energy of the
universe is exactly zero the matter in
the universe is made out of positive
energy now twice 0 is also 0 thus the
universe can double the amount of
positive matter energy and also
the negative gravitational energy with a
violation of the conservation of energy
and so they created this positive
negative nonsense I don't know if I
represented it properly there I have all
these smokey halo II kind of things and
I hope I hope that's what they're
talking about all that energy and how
they can tell the negative from the
positive there I don't know can you tell
me why is it because one is blue and the
other one's green or yellowish I mean
you know these people get away with
murder because they use this word this
undefined word energy which could all
Richard Fineman says you know we we have
no definition for and with us they're
gonna use this undefined term this
idiotic word that we've had for 2,000
years that nobody knows what it is and
with that they explain everything and no
kiddin I can do it with the word spirit
as well you know or angel or whatever I
can do it with God how's that I mean if
you don't have to define that term we
don't know what energy is and if you can
define it makes it even worse because
now you have a concept because objects
we point to then you know what is the
mechanism that they propose what is the
mechanism of energy coming into the
universe as a particle how did it go
from part from energy to particle that's
what we want to know we want to know the
mechanism
don't give me any math don't tell me
that look here we have positive energy
and we're gonna call this mass the other
one is negative gravity or whatever
that's all nonsense that's all
Burbage what we want to know is the
mechanism that's what we're interested
we want to know how mother nature runs
her shop okay so the issue is mechanisms
and that's what we don't have from
mathematical physics from quantum or
relativity or string theory for that
matter
okay how about mass next word underlying
here it is okay what do we have we have
mass is defined again if you can define
it it's not an object you have to be
able to point to mass if you can't point
to mass because it you know because it
doesn't have shape because it's a
concept then yeah it's a concept it's
not
okay it's not a standalone object can't
give you I can't bring to the conference
mass say look I've got this this is mass
I can't do that because mass is a number
it's a concept okay what is it well
first of all it lacks a definition we
have no idea what mass is in here yeah
we have proof evidence so that we can
convert and recruit here it is okay we
have three at least three testimonies
here we have Edwin Taylor and John
wheeler nature does not offer us any
concept as the amount of matter
history has struck down every proposal
to define such a term even if we could
count number of atoms or by any other
counting method try to evaluate a month
of matter that number would not equal
mass okay that's their opinion let's
find out if we got more opinions there
okay now we have in physical science
mathematics right what made this thing
is conceptually between at least seven
different aspects of mass or seven
physical notions that involve the
concept of mass how's that for a
definition so we have no idea because
there are some notions of of mass and
then just in case the physics frequency
frequently asked questions john biases
site over there at Riverside says when
the particle is at rest its relativistic
mass has a minimum value called the rest
mass okay as the particle is accelerated
to ever higher speeds its relativistic
mass increases without limit okay so
what is a good old biased talking about
well he's talking about he's talking
about wait see one thing no
Mathemagician even since the days of
newton has never been able to do is tell
you the difference between mass and
weight because they are synonyms and you
say bill you're crazy who do what are
you saying we learned this in high
school we know mass is different than
weight no no there's no difference
between mass and weight and I'm gonna
prove it to you okay so there idiot
please open your ears okay if we take
we had the grand Killough which is no
longer the standard but used to be the
standard French Killough that was in
Paris we take that French or let's let's
not even easier let's take a particle
right a a speck of dust and it's got
exactly exactly
consists of 1 million hydrogen atoms
how's that first star so we have a
little speck of dust and that speck of
dust is exactly exactly 1 million atoms
of hydrogen so far so good ok we take it
from the equator to the North Pole
it's way changed did its mass change
well people will say a lot of them
people will say well know that it's mass
then change what changes its weight well
how do you determine the mass of an
object well you wait you put it on a
scale and you weigh it and you give it
in terms of kilograms which is the way
you give weight kilograms and so the
question is you're saying that its mass
didn't change
what do you mean its mass did not change
but we still have a million atoms yep
but you never defined mass in terms of
quantity of matter especially when you
get to these relativistic masses where
they say oh the speed changes the mass
if the speed changes the mass we're
talking about weight and so these people
are calling it mass and what do they
mean they mean that they change the
number of atoms just because of its
speed what are we talking about so this
is the issue the issues they never
define the word mass scientific be in a
way that you can use it consistently and
these people are saying that they tell
you bla bla bla from their tongue out o
mass is different than weight because
this is quantity of matter no it ain't
so try again okay until you have a
definition of mass that we can apply
there to this little grain of sand and
consists of a million atom hydrogen
atoms and you take it somewhere else and
you tell me that the mass in change but
it weight the weight did and you tell me
in that context what has changed in
weight and what has not changed in mass
is it the quantity of hydrogen atoms so
again we have no definition we have no
difference between mass and weight until
someone can figure out what the
difference is and then of course we have
these other things these other issues
where you have the photon and the photon
is a so called particle that has no mass
then you have the black hole the other
end of the spectrum says infinite or
density you know it's got infinite mass
and no volume okay and so you have it if
the rest mass of the photon were nonzero
the theory of quantum electrodynamics
would be in trouble so thank God that
the photon has no rest mass okay and the
black hole's radius is zero which means
its density is infinite yeah we see
these declarations these statements
every day in the literature all nonsense
because here you have a massless
particle and you have a nothing a zero
dimensional singularity which has no
snow length with Earth's at our height
and it's got all the mass you want in
the universe it's infinite density so
what is it are these explanations valid
for four mechanisms but you know okay so
we have this black hole which I talked
about the other day and here you have
the good old mass you know swinging a
turtle around you could replace that
turtle with a star if you want I don't
care the point is how does mass do it I
want to know the physical mechanism how
is the turtle tied to that central mass
that is a singularity that is a black
hole and how does it compare the you
know the turtle do swing around it to
orbit it so that's what they have to
explain
I need a mechanism don't tell me mass
does it that's
manacle gibberish it has no place in in
fizzy fizzy so you gotta give me a
mechanism okay you gotta tell me what's
in contact with the skin of the turtle
that's what I need to figure out and
yeah for that they invented two words
one is wave and the other one is field
let's get to those okay so here we have
the wave okay what is the wave is this a
physical object standalone object and
can you bring me a wave and put in the
center of the conference room no first
if you can define it then it's not an
object okay you got a point to it second
wave is a verb wave is what something
does and it's the something that you
need to identify and in the case of wave
it's usually particles particles which
are vibrating so don't talk about the
wave talk about the particles why talk
about the wave what is it that's waving
well they say electrons are waves I
thought it was a particle
well these it's both whenever we need
the way we bring the wave whenever we
need the particle we bring the particle
whatever whatever suits our our theory
best you know you're gonna do the
Compton or a photoelectric effect well
then you bring the particle if you got
to do the photoelectric effect or the
slit experiment or maybe polarization
well then you bring the wave oh that's
in handy you just change in the middle
you change horses in the middle of the
row of the race right that's that's so
nice so so handy so ad hoc okay okay so
electrons are waves there are waves of
gravity okay and uh oh this again I'm
gonna present evidence proof so that we
have conversion here we have a
recruitment okay here it is so let's
just go through them one by one
electrons exhibit properties of both
particles and waves
okay so electrons are waves as well
double slit experiment shows the wave
expect of the electron yeah
gravitational waves are ripples in
space-time these cosmic ripples travel
at the speed of light carrying with them
carrying with them information how do
you carry information I mean on a
knapsack or what and then we have the
other one is light a waving of nothing
yeah if light is a wave then what is
doing the wavy and the physicist at the
ask the physicist answers in short
nothing nothing is really a wave itself
is it made of anything it's just a
propagation motion through the material
propagation of what what is moving
I thought motion involved the physical
object these people say that there is
nothing that is moving okay and just in
case we have the last one light travels
as a wave yeah light travels as a wave
it does not need any matter or material
to carry its energy along carry its
energy how do you carry energy I mean on
your back
piggyback somehow you know I don't know
how they carry energy so use these words
and you know when you criticize it they
say all you bill you're doing semantics
no no the guy doing semantics is the guy
who tries them who doing you into
thinking that that they can carry
information they can carry energy they
can carry a force you know move amass
bend time that's the person doing
semantics ok if you're gonna do a
physical interpretation if you're going
to do a a mechanism you need to put
objects there you can't put a cut a
dynamic concept can't put a concept to
begin with but to put a dynamic concept
makes it even worse it means you don't
even know the basics of science ok ok
and then we get to the famous word field
oh I love field feel this is my favorite
word ok here it is ok what is a field if
defined again if you can define the word
field it's because it's not an object ok
you should be able to point to a field
whatever our field is and it's better
have shape you got to make it visible I
need to see it ok does it mean a you
take me to the lab no I don't want to
see it in the lab I want to see it on
paper I want you to draw it on on the
board I want you to use crayons and you
know show the little baby and or the kid
and the toddler in kindergarten what a
field is that's what I want you to draw
it if it's got shape you better be able
to sketch it more or less
so that you can point to it say that's a
field okay is a standalone object well
that's fine now particle is an excited
field and here I've got a little gift
showing that and see if I can get it
here I think it's this one no it's not
well yeah here's the I'll show it in a
second but here's here's the definitions
that they have out there what is a field
of physical quantity so what's a
quantity what do we do with quantity I
mean are you gonna shake the quantity up
and down the numbers that has a value
for each each point in space-time so
what the hell is that
is that a field just a quantity or a
bunch of values around space-time around
the center point maybe extending
radially ever weaker as it gets away
from the center point is that what it is
that's not a physical object that's in
fact Mary allergy it's you're telling me
what something is made of first of all
but it's not even that good because
you're telling me it's made out of a
bunch of numbers a bunch of quantities a
bunch of amounts what the hell is that
you know I want to see that monster can
you bring it to the conference room
there are no particles there are only
fields okay at every point in space
there's dozens of little vibrating
fields what do you mean how can
quantities vibrate okay and in front of
you but quantum mechanics says that when
you look at the field closely enough
they resolve into individual particles
so so what you have is a bunch of
vibrating numbers amounts quantities
numbers and and when when you look at
him closely enough he says close enough
they need to resolve into particles
that's what this guy's a PhD supposedly
I don't know where he got his maybe
maybe at a monastery you know and then
the last one a point charges space in
into space its field will extend to
infinity so we have we have this
so-called field and it not only vibrates
locally it turns into a particle but it
extends to infinity okay
and so yeah when we look at some of the
claims that were made in the past and
now there were some of the definitions
that people made especially people like
Maxwell and what's-his-name Faraday here
I have there's their testimony they
speak from the tomb from from under the
ground and here it is okay maxilla self
filled the space in the neighborhood of
the electric and magnetic bodies in that
space there is matter in motion matter
in motion that's what a field is you
gotta identify what that matter is
something is vibrating something is
moving there you gotta identify what
that something is and Faraday's said I
cannot concede curved lines of force
speaking about magnetism right without
the conditions of a physical existence
in that intermediate space and he was uh
he studied magnetism and electricity in
quite a bit of detail so even though he
was not a very learned guy in the sense
he didn't have a PhD but he had a
practical understanding of magnets he
dealt with him a lot and he said look I
reached the conclusion that those lines
of force that the idiots of mathematics
today say well they're abstract they're
not real we just use them to to explain
no he says that's that's real that that
little line of force that's real and
Maxwell tells you the same thing he says
look there's matter in motion
it's those lines of force which are
moving around you know the threads
because that's what they look like
exactly like that and you say well bill
how do you know all that stuff I mean we
don't see and we can't tell well here
you see it here okay here you see it
here's a magnet pulling underwater
pulling one iron filing at a time one
iron filing at a time because there's
matter in motion sweeping around that
magnet and pulling each one of those
iron filings towards the magnet and you
know when you
let it sit you find all those lines of
force on which the iron filings sit and
yeah when you do that you know what are
you staying at you're staring at a bunch
of threads is going throw the iron
filings and keeping him there that's
what those lines of force are those
lines of force are real that's why
they're called lines of force because
that force is something that you can
feel not with your hands but by putting
something that is subject to that force
again anyone who knows a little bit
about inductance knows that the force
goes right through the coil and you put
something there and moves it so what
moved it you can't say the field moved
that because a field is a physical is
not a physical object field is an
abstract concept that is a dynamic
concept made of lines of force but you
have to identify what those lines of
force are and we identify them as
threads which are sweeping around the
magnet and now we can see why they break
up you know the iron filings because
there are physical entity which the iron
filing detects not you with your finger
so you're not gonna show it by going to
the lab and say let me touch that that
magnetic field now you won't be able to
touch the field or the lines of force
because Mother Nature specifically made
them invisible and intangible okay but
people insist on doing experiments
because they learn the scientific method
from the mathematical physicists and
they think that's science no no that's
not science in science we do not move
concepts and we do not go to the lab to
figure out what mediator we have for
light what mediator we have for gravity
of what mediate mediator we have for of
magnetic field or lines of force now you
got to sit back drink a couple beers and
visualize try to imagine what could be
moving those iron filings and if it's
matter in motion as mr. Maxwell tells us
and if they look like
lines of force as Faraday said which are
real it's very simple what you have is
threads moving around and all you got to
do is figure out how Mother Nature does
that tree and you know in my book the
one that I put out the other day the
Rope hypothesis you'll find it in the
description there we tell you how that's
done with threads do you believe it we
don't care it's science we do not
believe it's in religion where we
believe in science we explain so that
someone understands period that's where
science ends what continues is religion
belief opinion okay so we don't care
about your opinions here okay and and
then we get to charge see if I get it up
here got so many of these sometimes okay
so what do they say about charge well
charge is another word that completely
misused because again it's like a field
it's a number and people don't realize
there's no no it's the thing day you
always think it's a ball you no charge
it's the electron ball right even though
the electron is also a wave but that's
beside the point but what is charge
charge is the value of an electron of
mathematical value and they say oh we
move the charge no no yet you couldn't
move a charge you maybe you moved an
electron ball we can accept that if the
electron is a ball but you can't say you
move the charge you can't say you're
gonna you're gonna move the ten tons now
you've moved the elephant not the ten
tons if you want to do a physical
interpretation if you want to give a
mechanism you got to put the elephant
back you can't say well I'm gonna move
ten tons know that that's what the
elephant way you can't say you're gonna
move his weight you're gonna move the
elephant in physics not the ten tons
people don't understand that okay and
this is very important of course and let
me tell you why you can't put elephant
in your equation you put elephant in
their previous era would is that it it
is the letter e a variable constant what
is it elephant no no they they have to
put ten times because they can deal with
that they can't put a in the equation of
bezel probably
flatten the equation out okay so if it's
defined it's not an object period so
it's gotta be so if if if if if it's a
physical object just got a point to it
and what is the charge can you point to
a charge and you tell me what it looks
like is it a little ball a little is it
a circle is a two-dimensional
three-dimensional you got a point to it
if you can't point to it if you got to
define it automatically it's not an
object its concepts we define objects
which we point to and you got to keep
that straight if you don't keep that
straight you're in a rational individual
that's period we're done there's not
much more to say about that and we have
a definition for irrationality I'm not
gonna deal with that right now but if
you look up you'll find a video of mine
that talks about that anyways what is
charge it's one point six times ten to
the minus nineteen coulombs what is a
Coulomb not important a unit some kind
of unit it's a number that's what it is
that's what charge is it's a number okay
assign to the electron and proton for
that matter but typically used in the
context of electrons negative charge
they caught it okay
no stand alone object is called charge
you can't bring a standalone charge and
bring it to the conference room and no
positive or negative in physics you know
we don't use this positive negative
energy positive and negative charge not
in physics fit or positive negative
poles of a magnet positive and they just
mean opposite that's all positive and
negative mean the mathematicians have no
idea what positive and negative mean in
physical terms mechanisms so what if if
a magnet is negative here positive there
you can't just say well how does a
magnet attract another one well a
positive attracts negative so what did
you say
you said X attracts Y is that what you
said you said black attracts white what
are you saying no no we need to see a
mechanism if you don't have a mechanism
you haven't explained how this universe
works that's what we want to understand
we want to know how mother nature does
her daily stuff
how she runs her shop so you got to tell
me how Mother Nature does gravity how
she does like how she does magnetism how
she does electricity house how though
how she manages the workings of an atom
that's what you got to tell me the
mechanism if you can't tell me the
mechanism I got is a mathematical
description that's worthless in physics
that's okay in religion of method maths
you know description we need a little
more than that we need an explanation
for how mother nature does her
mechanisms and charge doesn't help us in
that regard because man charge is just a
number field is just a number energy is
just a number mass is just a number
they're all numbers with units we can't
do anything with that we can't say that
you know so many herbs of energy costs
cause the wall to fall we can't do that
not in you know you you gotta identify
the physical object that came in contact
with a wall that's how we do it in
physics and that's where we separate the
mathematical physicists so called
physics with throw genuine physicists
okay okay with that I will see you on
Wednesday and I'll see you on Wednesday
okay and we're gonna continue with this
line of battering of mathematical
physics I hope you tune in and if you're
a mathematical physics this I hope you
have second thoughts about your religion
we'll see you then
bye bye